so city of New Orleans Mayor Mitch
Landrieu has begun the process of
removing for Confederate memorials this
process started on yesterday now this is
not the first time the city of New
Orleans has tried to do away with these
Confederate memorials and to be sure
these memorials expressly one of them
the first one that came down expressly
endorses white supremacy actually on the
monument the phrase white supremacy is
there and again this is not the first
time they tried to remove it nineteen
eighty-one and nineteen ninety-three
they gave they tried twice but there
were over 31,000 signatures collected
between those two times trying to
prevent the monuments from coming down
well finally after all the effort these
for monuments are coming down and I want
you to understand the kind of situation
that they're in the workers who
dismantled it had to wear flak jackets
helmets and scarves and they also had to
conceal their identities because of
concerns for their safety this is how
deeply entrenched the Confederacy is in
the south we're not talking about we're
not talking about just simple monuments
these are these are actual monuments to
it you know to say the treacherous
Confederacy is one thing but it's
Confederacy combined with the white
supremacy so and to be sure now this is
you know their arguments over whether or
not the Confederacy is heritage or hate
I we don't really have time to go into
that but I want you to understand how
clearly enshrined white supremacy was on
the obelisk that was taken down today
the between 1932 and up until nineteen
ninety-three the monument had a plaque
on it that said that the national
election of November 1876 recognized
white supremacy in the south and gave us
our state so this is not it it's not
really a question of you know all the
Confederacy's or family as a heritage
our legacy you know will argue about
that another time we're talking about
clearly enshrined white supremacy in
monuments that took I mean took three
efforts to get down yeah it's literally
written in stone there it's as clear as
you can get and you know luckily we're
seeing the trend of the Confederate flag
being taken away from government
buildings but it takes a long time you
know Mississippi did
officially ratified a 13th amendment
banning slavery until nineteen
ninety-five Pat you always you never
cease to amaze me I did not know that
Wow and I and I grew up in Mississippi
but it mayor Landrieu this is what he
said about it he said the removal of
these statues sent a clear message clear
and unequivocal message to the people of
New Orleans in the nation New Orleans
celebrates our diversity inclusion and
tolerance this is not about politics
blame or retaliation this is not a naive
request a quest to solve all of our
problems at once this is about showing
the whole world that we as a city and as
a people are able to acknowledge
understand and reconcile and most
importantly choose a better future I
could not agree with them more it's not
about relitigate in the past simply by
saying that we want to stay here then we
can move to a better place so that's
Mayor Mitch Landrieu of New Orleans